[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
heute gibt es ein richtig leckeres
rezept vom grill wir sind wieder hier
draußen auf unserer terrasse und heute
gibt etwas ganz besonderes nämlich
stromboli das ist so eine art gefüllte
pizza oder stromboli und dazu gibt es
einen richtig leckeren grillkäse und ich
möchte euch jetzt auch schon verraten es
gibt ein ganz ganz tolles gewinnspiel
bei dem ihr gerade ganz toll mitmachen
könnt und einem von zehn wie green eggs
gewinnen könnt aber dann erzähle ich
später noch was dazu ich werde später
hier den gasgrill und von käse verwenden
und das ist praktisch ein richtig toller
vegetarische alternative auch zu fleisch
gerade wenn ihr sagt ihr wollt grillen
aber nicht immer fleisch essen oder auch
eine ergänzung zu fleisch denn bei uns
ist es keinen wenn oder oder sondern es
ist einfach ein begriff heute und dann
gibt's halt grill oder pfanne käse noch
mit dazu und hier gibt es einmal die
natur variante und die kräuter variante
beide sind bio wenn ich ganz toll und
den bereit ich später einfach mit dazu
und stromboli ist so eine art gefüllte
pizza die man auch gerne als appetizer
ist und gerade wenn man draußen grillt
finde ich das echt schön weil man eben
alles draußen zubereiten kann und dann
auch relativ schnell fertig ist muss ich
sagen als ich stelle mal kurz zur seite
und zeigt euch die zutaten für den teig
denn damit geht es gleich los und ich
werde erst den teig zubereiten dann den
grill vorheizen und dann praktisch alles
füllen und direkt grill und dann sind
wir fertig für den teig verwende ist 5
gramm hefe einen esslöffel zucker
225 gramm wasser 450 gramm mehl da könnt
ihr dinkel oder weizenmehl verwenden
einen teelöffel salz und etwas olivenöl
und ihr könnt jetzt den teig gern in der
küchenmaschine zubereiten aber wir sind
jetzt hier outdoor und machen das ist
einfach so ich brauchte auch relativ
wenig hefe dafür mit zucker und wasser
verrühren
tatsächlich erinnert mich das teig
selber kneten immer an meine mama weil
es halt echt so bis zum schluss immer
noch einfach per hand macht ohne kühnen
maschine obwohl sie daheim ein haar trug
dann das mehl dazu
[Musik]
und da gucke ich immer dass ich erst
recht wenig mehr nehmen und dann so nach
und nach das ganze mail einarbeite
zum schluss dann auch immer erst salz
dazu
[Musik]
dann können wir jetzt hier nach und nach
das mehl und auch öl dazugeben und den
teig schön kneten
[Musik]
am ende einfach schön durchkneten am
besten immer mit dem handball oder mit
der faust aber nicht mit den fingern
denn dann verkrampfen die finger
irgendwann auch mal kann sogar nicht
mehr kneten von hefeteig da braucht
schon so ein bisschen liebe also zehn
minuten könnte da gerne magneten
dann wird da immer schön und immer
geschmeidiger
ich mache jetzt einfach so fünf minuten
rechts fünf minuten links und dann spare
ich mir heute das abendtraining
[Musik]
und dann die oberfläche schön mit öl
fetten damit sie nicht austrocknet und
dann lege ich den tag zurück in die
schüssel decken ab dann kann er schön
aufgehen und ich kann ihnen der
zwischenzeit schon mal den grill
vorheizen dann hat sich jetzt um einen
grill vor ich habe das big green egg und
bin richtig glücklich damit weil ich
einfach sehr gut damit zurecht komme es
speichert die hitze perfekt ich kann
darin direkt oder indirekt grillen und
garn auf verschiedenen ebenen und ich
bin einfach happy denn ich weiß auch
mittlerweile über den krieg selber an
macht ohne dass ich den murat dafür
braucht ohne grillanzünder ohne
brennspiritus und so weiter ich habe
hier die kohle und dann kommt die hier
in die schale rein praktisch bis zur
erster linie
das eine riesen dank aufgeht
[Musik]
ja
so schön verteilt und da sieht man ganz
schön dass die kohle einfach große und
kleine stücke hat sich alles gleichmäßig
erhitzt und wirklich auch lange warm
bleibt das ist nämlich wichtig das ist
einfach lange die gleiche temperatur
hält
[Musik]
und wenn die kohle dann verteilt ist
einfach nur an zinsen dann nämlich mit
der luft leiter dafür den gibt's mit
kabel und auch ohne tatsächlich ich hab
natürlich mal den mit kabel dar weil wir
hier auf der terrasse sind ohne kabel
muss man halt immer dran denken dass da
eben auch geladen ist aber mit dem
klappt das so bereich entzündliche
einfach so zwei drei stellen macht den
grill zu und macht natürlich oben und
unten so das loch auf damit ein durchzug
herrscht und das feuer auch schnell
brennt
[Musik]
das war's schon dann verschließe ich den
grill hier oben ist offen unten der
schacht der muss auch geöffnet werden
damit sauerstoff rein kommt und die
kohle schön leuchten und klönen und
brennen kann ja dann hole ich jetzt
schon mal die zutaten für die füllung
der
grill ist schön aufgeheizt und jetzt
kann ich den hier einstellen das heißt
ich schließe den schacht hier oben einen
spalt unten auch
so regelt sich die temperatur ein und
ich kann dann bei ungefähr 250 grad mein
stromboli gleich gar beim aufmachen
immer darauf achten erstmal ein spalt
und dann komplett öffnen und dann kann
ich das hier jetzt schon mal einsetzen
und auch gleich den pizza steigen was
ich aber immer ganz gern mache auch
tatsächlich immer noch mal mit der
bürste drüber gehen wenn es gleich heiß
wird man muss auch sagen dass der grill
gar nicht putz intensiv ist also wir
machen da einfach so gar nichts dran
denn am ende nach dem grill mache ich
praktisch den schacht oben und unten auf
oder entsteht so eine pyrolyse und es
reinigt sich alles von selbst
große silber praktisch
genau dann kommt ihr ziel gleich auf der
pizza schreiben drauf und ich werde die
füllung schon mal zu bereiten für mein
stromboli nehme ich etwas kräuterbutter
paprika mark und tomatenmark und als
füllung etwas salami putenbrust oregano
etwas kasperl käse das ist käse von
ghazi champignons und eine rote paprika
und zum bestreichen und bestreitet das
olivenöl oregano und myspace oder
hartweizengrieß ich nehme cd
kräuterbutter das paprika mark und
tomatenmark und kann die zutaten schön
vermischen da muss jetzt auch nichts
mehr würzen die kräuterbutter findet ihr
auch auf meinem kanal da habe ich schon
ein rezept dazu hochgeladen und das
paprika mag ist auch meist schon so ein
bisschen vor gewürzt deswegen da einfach
mal ab schmecken wenn ihr noch ein
bisschen salz verbraucht dann gern dazu
geben aber die füllung ist ja auch schon
seit 40
das ist hier nämlich so eine richtig
schöne würzige passte
die kann ich schon mal zur seite legen
und dann die paprika und die champignons
schneiden
[Musik]
draußen spart man sich schön in die
biotonne
[Musik]
und den käse dann einfach schön reiben
dann habe ich jetzt hier meinen
pizzateig da jetzt wunderbar aufgegangen
ist wenn man sehen kann
daraus werde ich jetzt denke drei
kleinere stromboli zaubern zwei große
sind okay aber ich finde so kleine dass
das ist schön
als einfach den teig dritteln
jeweils zu einer kugel kurzformen
und immer den teig der mann noch nicht
braucht einfach noch mal weg legen und
abdecken damit er nicht austrocknet
[Musik]
dann wollte den teig jetzt einfach schön
eckig aus
[Musik]
wenn ich dann so ein schönes rechteck
habt kommt jetzt hier praktisch diese
kräuter tomaten butter drauf
am besten nicht ganz bis zum rand damit
sie nicht raus läuft
etwas salami und hähnchenbrust wenn ihr
möchtet
[Musik]
da packte jetzt einfach alle zutaten
rein die ihr eben gerne mögt so ein
bisserl was würziges am besten aber auch
zutaten die nicht so sehr wässern also
jetzt keine tomaten zum beispiel da
würde ich einfach empfehlen dass ich sie
vorher zum beispiel word oder
getrocknete tomaten verwendet
damit es eben richtig schön gegart wird
auf dem grill
oregano
habe ich ja aus dem garten
[Musik]
und natürlich den
pascal keese von ghazi
das ist einfach der mit den besten
schmelz eigenschaften muss ich echt
sagen
[Musik]
dann die champignons und paprika stücke
noch drauf und schön aufrollen
[Musik]
dann aufholen
und am ende wirklich gut zu drücken und
auch hier gut zu drücken damit da
wirklich nichts austritt
und dann noch mit olivenöl beträufeln
mit etwas gries und oregano bestreuen
und fertig
[Musik]
toyotas
jetzt habe ich hier schon mal den pizza
steinen vorgeheizt und da stehe ich auch
so ein bisschen gries drauf ihr könnt
das stromboli natürlich auch im backofen
zubereiten und entfernen käse dann in
der pfanne aber ich bereite alles auf
dem grill zu und dann kann ich jetzt
hier in strom politischen grillen
und gleich nebendran auf dem grillrost
nämlich den grill und pfanne käse
mein strom wohl ist es gleich fertig man
sieht es auch erst noch schön hell
browns braucht noch ein paar minuten und
damit gleich alles gleichzeitig fertig
ist packe ich jetzt den grillkäse noch
mit drauf wie gesagt nämlich jetzt den
biogas und pfannen käse einmal gibt es
in die natur und in kräuter und was
jetzt ganz besonders ist es gibt nämlich
noch ein großes gewinnspiel bis ende
august da könnt ihr gerne daran
teilnehmen und zwar braucht ihr dafür
eine aktions packung das seht ihr hier
auch auf der rückseite da es oder grill
abgebildet und in der packung drin ist
ein code den ihr scannen könnt und dann
könnt ihr bis ende august einen 15
between ex gewinnen und das ist wirklich
der hammer muss ich sagen denn es werden
auch monatlich schon gewinner gezogen
das heißt wenn ihr damals mit macht
könnt ihr auch mehrmals einen gewinn ihr
habt einfach mehrmals die chance zu
sagen teilzunehmen und ich nehme jetzt
hier mal den käse raus ich mach jetzt
biste natur dürfen die kinder ganz gern
mit kräutern mag ich ganz gerne und wie
gesagt alle infos stehen dann auch da
drin und am besten ist auch wenn er
direkt gas sie auf instagram folgt das
ga sie unterstrich food da könnt ihr
nämlich immer alle infos auch sehen und
das ist echt schön
und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr den käse
entweder in der pfanne zubereiten steht
auch auf der packung rückseite oder eben
auf dem grill von beiden seiten etwa
drei minuten wer möchte kann ihn gern
noch mit olivenöl zum beispiel betroffen
und ganz schön grillen
[Musik]
moral von mira essen ist fertig
aha ok damit müssen wir das jetzt auch
schon da st
und es geht war stromboli mit grillkäse
das hört sich immer an denen gesagt wie
stranguliert stromboli
so heißt es aber wollte mal probieren ja
und zwar ist es noch nicht gewollte
gefüllte pizza sozusagen also dass viele
calzone nur auf nur auf gerade mal
eine salami
putenbrust bisschen gemüse der schluck
so kratzer deluxe
ich weiß nicht was krawall show aus
karatschi das hat es früher eine
tankstelle gehen das war so als wenn wir
durften müssen die essen so
wahrscheinlich und dazu grillkäse
so probiert mal
das aus stück haben
er streitet euch warum es nicht er ist
einfach
gut ich mich mit viel elan
der ärgert dich
und grillkäse probieren sie hat eben
schon gejubelt als sie den grillkäse
gesehen hat
immer lecker
das gut mir sagen so lecker schmeckt
ich freue mich jetzt auch tatsächlich
selbst essen das heißt für euch ihr
könnt das rezept gern nachlesen auf
salehs - blog.de aufgabe findet ihr das
rezept auch und wie gesagt von euch am
besten echte aktionspackungen da ist
nämlich das gewinnspiel mit dabei ihr
könnt einen von zehn big green eggs
gewinnen und dann zu hause auch ganz
tolle gerichte zaubern um exakt bis zum
31 august könnt ihr da gerne noch
mitmachen jeden monat gibt es gewinne
werden gewinner gezogen deswegen viel
glück viel erfolgreich und zum guten
appetit und euch dann auch bis zum
nächsten wahl
papa war auch noch hier und papa auch
gleich mit es war
wieso essen am tisch fallen
[Musik]
fielmann
das ding die schwerste will ist mir ein
was den tag meines lebens genau dann
wenn sich kaputtlachen versteckst wird
er soll die kamera ausmachen doch ein
solcher austausch
lass ich mich scheiden
[Musik]